اطول معارك هذه الحرب
هذا خط الدفاع الاوكراني الاخير عن ضخمه
وهنا يتحصن الجند في شبكه من الخنادق في
احياء المدينه الغربيه
سامس يقول الجني انهم يجعلون في خنادقهم
من الجثث سواتر لهم من النيران الروسيه
والروس ماضون في تحقيق مكاسب في مزيد من
اجزاء المدينه المدمره لا يقرون دائما
بانها مكلفه تقول القوات الاوكرانيه انها
لا تفتح تصد عمليات هجوميه روسيه على
مناطق عده في بخموت كما تؤكد استمرار
القتال في مواجهه القوات الروسيه ايضا
باتجاه
ومارينكا وليمان شرقي البلاد
الى من تقع عمان على الضفه الغربيه من نهر
المدينه تعرضت الجمعه لهجوم روسي واسع
النطاق بالصواريخ والمسيرات استهدف
مقاطعات في وسط البلاد وجنوبها لم يكد
يمضي يوم على الواقعه حتى هز انفجار هناك
جنوبا خزان وقود بمنطقه خليج الكوزاق في
مدينه سيفا ستوبل المدينه هي الميناء
الرئيسي لاسطول البحر الاسود الروسي في
شبه جزيره القرم تقول المخابرات
الاوكرانيه الى الهجوم جاء عقابا طويل
الامد ردا على استهداف الروس مدينه اومان
الاوكرانيه
نصحت سكان شبه جزيره القرم التي ضمتها
موسكو قبل سنوات بالابتعاد عن المنشات
العسكريه الروسيه
وتحرير القرن كما يقول الاوكرانيون سيكون
في قلب الهجوم المضاد الذي يتوعدون به منذ
فتره يبدو انها مساله وقت فحتى مالك شركه
فاجنر العسكريه الخاصه يعتقد ان الجيش
الاوكراني مستعد لتنفيذ ذلك الهجوم على
القوات الروسيه قبل الخامسه عشر من شهر
مايو المقبل بالنسبه
فان الاحوال الجويه وربما بعض المشكلات
الداخليه هي ما شكلت حتى الان عائقا امام
اقدام القوات الاوكرانيه على تلك الخطوه
الاوكراني يرهل الرئيس فولو نجاح بلاده في
هجومها المضاد المنتظر بمدى استمرار
حصولها على الاسلحه الغربيه
تكثفت اخيرا وتيره تصليح نوعي لكيف مع
تزايد التزام حلفائها الغربيين بوعودهم
صارت مثلا انظمه الامريكيه للدفاع الجوي
الصاروخي فعاله منذ فتره في اوكرانيا
قد تكون عامله ارباك المحتملا للخطط
الروسيه وغطاء لاي عمل هجومي مضاد ذاك
الذي تقول وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان
دونه الان مساله الطقس وقرار القاده